JESSE AND GERALDO.
THIS IS "THE FIVE" IN NEW YORK
CITY.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI RUSHING TO
BE BY THE SIDE OF HER HUSBAND,
PAUL AS WE GET NEW DETAILS ON
THIS ACT OF VIOLENCE.
PAUL PELOSI BRUTALLY ATTACKED
WITH A HAMMER INSIDE THEIR
SAN FRANCISCO HOME IN THE EARLY
HOURS OF THE MORNING.
REPORTEDLY THE SUSPECT WAS
SHOTTING "WHERE IS NANCY" WHEN
THE SPEAKER ENTERED THE HOUSE.
SHE WAS NOT THERE.
NEW VIDEO SHOWS A SMASHED GLASS
DOOR.
POLICE RESPONDED TO A WELLNESS
CHECK.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF THAT IS A HOME
ALARM OR A CALL FROM PAUL
PELOSI.
IT HAPPENED AROUND 2:30 A.M.
WHEN THEY ENCOUNTERED THIS.
>> OUR OFFICERS OBSERVED
MR. PELOSI AND THE SUSPECT BOTH
HOLDING THE HAMMER.
THE SUSPECT PULLED THE HAMMER
AWAY FROM MR. PELOSI AND
VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED HIM WITH IT.
OUR OFFICERS TACKLED THE SUSPECT
AND DISARMED HIM AND TOOK HIM IN
TO CUSTODY AND REQUESTED
EMERGENCY BACKUP AND RENDERED
MEDICAL AID.
>> Martha: SO IT'S NOT CLEAR
FROM THE CHIEF'S COMMENTS WHO
WAS HOLDING THE HAMMER OR
WHETHER THE SUSPECT BROUGHT IT
WITH HIM AND USED IT TO ENTER
THE HOME OR WHETHER MR. PELOSI
GRABBED IT AFTER HE HEARD
SOMEBODY BREAKING IN TO HIS
HOME.
THE A 82-YEAR-OLD REMAINS
HOSPITALIZED.
DOCTORS ARE TREATING HIM AND
TOLD HE WILL MAKE A FULL
RECOVERY.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY UPDATES.
WE KNOW SPEAKER PELOSI IS ON HER
WAY TO WITH WITH HIM.
THE SUSPECT IS IN CUSTODY AND
FACES SEVERAL CHARGES INCLUDING
ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE AND ELDER
ABUSE.
POLICE ARE LOOKING TO DETERMINE
A MOTIVE.
PEOPLE THAT KNOW HIM HAD SOME
BIZARRE BEHAVIOR.
THE SUSPECT WAS SEEN AT TIMES TO
BE OUT OF TOUCH WITH REALITY.
HE HAD TROUBLE WITH EYE CONTACT.
THEY SAID THAT THEY CUT OFF
CONTACT WITH HIM.
ONE OF THEM HE WAS HOUSE SITTING
FOR THEM.
HE WAS CREEPING HER OUT.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO BE IN TOUCH
ANYMORE.
SO YOU KNOW, THE BIG QUESTION
HERE IS WHETHER THIS IS
REFLECTIVE OF POLITICAL VIOLENCE
THAT IS HAPPENING IN THE COUNTRY
OR WHETHER IT'S REFLECTIVE OF
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN
THE COUNTRY AND VIOLENCE IN
GENERAL ACROSS THE COUNTRY OR
SOME COMEBACK OF BOTH.
KENNEDY?
>> I THINK YOU HIT ON IT.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF BOTH.
I THINK WHERE WE'RE AT, THE
PRESIDENT PROMISED TO BRING DOWN
THE TENOR OF POLITICAL
DISCOURSE.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED.
PEOPLE ARE MORE DIVIDED.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT SEE WORDS AS
VIOLENCE AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT IT'S VERY EASY FOR THEM TO
CROSS THE LINE AND COMMIT ACTS
OF VIOLENCE LIKE THIS BECAUSE
THEY ARE MOVED BY THEIR
POLITICS.
WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT KIND OF
RAGE, THAT SORT OF SYSTEMIC
CULTURAL RAGE THAT WE HAVE THAT
HASN'T CALMED DOWN WITH
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS, THAT'S
WHEN YOU HAVE THINGS LIKE THIS
HAPPEN.
FOR ANYONE, WHETHER IT'S A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE, THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE OR ANYONE
THAT HOLDS VISIBLE ELECTIVE
OFFICE, IT'S A REALLY SCARY
TIME.
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
SO MUCH MONEY GOES TO SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT RIGHT.
THEY HAVE FAILED THE MENTALLY
ILL, ESPECIALLY THOSE VIOLENTLY
MENTALLY ILL IN THAT STATE.
THEY HAVE NOT CREATED
APPROPRIATE SYSTEMS TO IDENTIFY
AND TREAT PEOPLE LIKE THIS.
IT'S REALLY SAD THAT AFTER THE
FACT WE'RE HEARING ABOUT ALL OF
THESE SYMPTOMS WHEN, YOU KNOW,
WITH ALL OF THAT MONEY AND ALL
OF THOSE RESOURCES, SOMEONE LIKE
THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AND TREATED BEFORE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENED.
>> Martha: TYRUS, I COULDN'T
HELP BUT THINK OF THE WOMAN ON
HER WAY TO THE AIRPORT IN NEW
YORK CITY A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
SHE WAS THROWN TO THE GROUND,
KICKED IN THE HEAD.
SHE WAS IN DANGER OF LOSING HER
EYESIGHT.
SHE KNOWS WHAT IT FEELS LIKE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
PUSHED IN SUBWAY TRACKS BY
SIMILARLY MENTALLY UNFIT
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
>> THE FIRST THING, WE WISH HIM
A SPEEDY RECOVERY.
WE HAVE TO SAY THANK GOD FOR THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THEY WERE ABLE TO RESPONDS TO A
CALL, GET THERE JUST IN TIME TO
SAVE HIS LIFE.
BECAUSE AS THEY ARRIVED, HE WAS
BEING PUMMELED WITH A HAMMER.
IF THE POLICE WEREN'T THERE, IT
WOULD HAVE ENDED UP LIKE A LOT
OF THOSE VIDEOS YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT WHERE THE CRIMINAL WOULD
HAVE TOOK HIS TIME AND JUST
CONTINUED TO BE PUMMELED.
SO ONE, THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT YOUR POLICE
OFFICERS AND YOUR POLICES IN
YOUR COMMUNITY SO THEY CAN GET A
WELLNESS CALL OR A 9-11 CALL AND
BE THERE IN A RAPID MANNER TO
HELP SAVE YOUR LIFE.
SO GOOD THING.
LET'S JUST BE HAPPY THAT IN HIS
PARTICULAR NEIGHBORHOOD, THE
POLICE WERE ABLE TO RESPOND AND
BE THERES BECAUSE A LOT OF US IN
A LOT OF CITIES IN THIS COUNTRY,
YOU CALL AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
BE THERE.
SO LET'S JUST BE REALLY HAPPY
THAT THAT HAPPENED.
>> Martha: GOOD POINTS.
GERALDO?
>> I THINK SOMETIMES THINGS ARE
AS SIMPLE AS THEY APPEAR.
HERE YOU HAVE A GUY WEARING HIS
UNDERWEAR, CLEARLY A CRAZY GUY.
HIS SOCIAL MEDIA INDICATING THAT
HE'S IN TO WACKY CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
HE'S SCREAMING LOOKED TO ME THE
WAY THE BACK WINDOW WAS SMASHED
OUT, HE TOOK NO CAUTION IN
SNEAKING IN TO THE HOUSE.
HE WAS BUSTING IN.
HE DIDN'T CARE WHO HEARD HIM.
WHEN -- I'M JUST SURMISING THAT
PAUL PELOSI HEARS THIS HUGE
COMMOTION, HITS THE BUTTON, GOES
DOWNSTAIRS TO SEE WHAT'S UP.
PICKS UP THE HAMMER AROUND
HESITATES BEFORE HE USES IT WHEN
HE SEES THE NUT JOB.
THIS IS A POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
CRAZY PERSON.
I THINK THE DISCUSSION ON MENTAL
ILLNESS IS AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION TO HAVE.
I THINK THE DANGER IS THAT BY
COMBINING THE TWO ISSUES, THE
ASSAULT ON PELOSI AND MENTAL
ILLNESS, YOU TEND TO ABSOLVE OR
MITIGATE OR DIMINISH THE
RESPONSIBILITY, THE CRIMINAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE PERSON WHO
ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE.
THE PERSON WHO ATTEMPTED TO KILL
THE HUSBAND AND THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE.
THE PERSON THAT SAID WHERE'S
NANCY, WHERE'S NANCY AND WOULD
HAVE PERFORMED AS VIOLENTLY IF
THE SPEAKER WAS ACTUALLY IN
THERE.
HOW TRAGIC WOULD THAT HAVE BEEN,
THE NUMBER 3 RANKED PERSON IN
THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT ASSAILED
AND KILLED BY A NUT JOB.
>> Martha: JESSE, I'M STRUCK
BECAUSE WE DO SO MANY STORIES OF
PEOPLE BEING ATTACKED VIOLENTLY.
A HUMAN BEING IS A HUMAN BEING
WHETHER YOU'RE PAUL PELOSI OR
THE WOMAN GETTING HER HEAD
KICKED IN ON THE WAY TO WORK.
THERE'S ALL OF THIS CONCERN
ABOUT PROTECTING OUR LAWMAKERS.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS HAPPEN
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS
COUNTRY BUT THE PROBLEM IS IT'S
HAPPENING TO LOTS OF REGULAR
FOLKS EVERY DAY.
>> Jesse: IT'S HAPPENING TO
EVERYBODY.
DOESN'T MATTER WHO YOU ARE.
YOU HAVE TO WATCH OUT.
I HOPE HE'S BETTER.
I HOPE HE RECOVERS QUICKLY.
GETTING HIT IN THE HEAD WITH A
HAMMER DOES NOT SOUND FUN AT
ALL.
HE'S HAD A ROUGH YEAR.
HE ALMOST DIED IN A CAR ACCIDENT
AND NOW ALMOST DIED FROM A
HAMMER ATTACK.
I WISH HIM AND HIS WIFE WELL AND
A SPEEDY RECOVERY.
THE GUY THAT IS THE ALLEGED
ATTACKER SOUNDS LIKE A HOMELESS
NUDIST.
HE WAS LIVING IN A STORAGE
LOCKER AND HE WAS AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN FROM CANADA WITH A RAP
SHEET IN SAN FRANCISCO.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DEPORTED.
BUT  SAN FRANCISCO IS A
SANCTUARY CITY.
THERE'S A CRIME WAVE.
IT'S NOW COME TO THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE'S HOUSE.
IT CAME TO ZELDIN'S HOUSE.
HE'S A CONGRESSMAN RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR HERE.
SOMEONE RUSHED THE STAGE.
KAREN BASS RUNNING FOR MAJOR IN
LOS ANGELES HAD GUNS STOLEN.
IT'S HAPPENING ACROSS THE BOARD.
WHAT I WANT IS THAT I WANT THIS
ALLEGED PERPETRATOR TO BE
TREATED THE EXACT SAME WAY IF HE
HAD TREATED -- IF HE ATTACKED
ANYBODY ELSE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE GET HIT WITH
HAMMERS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE GET ATTACKED.
A LOT OF THE TIMES THEY'RE OUT
ON BAIL THE NEXT DAY.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS GUY IS
BEING TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
HE'S FACING WHAT?
ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE?
HE'S IN PRISON RIGHT NOW?
WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE ASSAULT PEOPLE
ALL THE TIME RANDOMLY WITH ALL
KINDS OF WEAPONS.
WE SEE THEM RELEASED THE NEXT
DAY.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS GUY IS
GETTING ALL OF A SUDDEN SPECIAL
TREATMENT OR DIFFERENT TREATMENT
BECAUSE THE VICTIM WAS SO HIGH
PROFILE.
REMEMBER, IF YOU CALL ON A
WELFARE CHECK, THE LEFT WANTS TO
SEND A SOCIAL WORKER.
WHAT IF A SOCIAL WORKER HAD COME
TO THIS CALL?
YOU WOULD HAVE HAD A DEAD
HUSBAND AND A DEAD SOCIAL
WORKER.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO HAVE
POLICE.
I AGREE WITH TYRUS, THE POLICE
HANDLED THE SITUATION.
THANK GOD THE POLICE WERE THERE
AND REMEMBER, THE DEMOCRATS
DEFUNDED THE POLICE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
BIG MISTAKE.
THEY PUT THE MONEY BACK IN.
BUT THESE ARE THE MISTAKES THAT
WE CANNOT KEEP MAKING.
>> THIS GUY WAS TRYING TO KILL
HIM IN FRONT OF THE COPS.
THE COPS WERE THERE.
HE'S SMASHING HIM WITH A HAMMER.
HE'S LUCKY HE WASN'T SHOT AND
KILLED.
>> Jesse: THEY USED A LOT OF
DISCRETION.